une démonstration de force en son et
lumière pour eric zemmour à lille le
candidat de reconquête s'est livré à une
diatribe contre l'assistanat devant plus
de 6000 personnes
dans les classes les plus populaires
jusqu'aux classes moyennes on délaisse
l'assistanat quand on se lève chaque
matin à 5 heures pour aller travailler
quand on gagne difficilement sa vie à la
sueur de son front on n'accepte pas que
le voisin vivre mieux que soi grâce à
des aides sociales sans avoir besoin
la valorisation de l'effort avec un clin
d'oeil au mantra de nicolas sarkozy de
2007 travailler plus pour gagner plus
comme un appel du pied aussi aux
électeurs de valérie pécresse eux aussi
sensible au sujet et qui dit retrouver
du pouvoir d'achat dit aussi pour eric
zemmour cesser de gaspiller l'argent
public parmi ces dépenses folles mes
amis vous le savez
tous les français le savent il y a le
financement de l'immigration oui mes
amis sauvé le pouvoir d'achat des
français s'est également arrêté de
financer l'immigration sur votre dos
c'est arrêter de dilapider l'argent pris
dans vos poches même ma personne
pour nourrir le monde entier
à plus de 200 km au sud reims ville du
sacre des rois de france la candidate du
rassemblement national à d'entrée de jeu
voulu marquer son style plus offensif
contre ses adversaires à commencer par
l'actuel chef de l'état
bousculés à l'intérieur humilié à
l'extérieur la france dégringole dans le
classement des puissances un publi par
les erreurs la vanité et le cynisme des
manuels macron
zone 3000 et trahison ni les embuscades
ni les manoeuvres je n'ai comme boussole
que l'intérêt supérieur de notre pays et
de notre peuple la france nous attend
baisse de la tva sur le gaz et les
carburants aide aux familles
monoparentales pas de retraite en
dessous de 1000 euros pendant plus d'une
heure marine le pen a égrainé ces
mesures devant un électorat populaire
déjà acquis à sa cause comme pour son
rival à il réussit le pouvoir d'achat
passe par une lutte contre la fraude et
l'immigration pas politique en matière
d'immigration
tiendra en croit principe 1 la france
restera maîtresse de sa politique
migratoire
2 les étrangers qui veulent venir
devront subvenir à leurs besoins
3 c'est nous qui déciderons qui peut
rester ou qui doit partir
à la fin de son discours celle qui se
présente pour la troisième fois à
l'élection présidentielle a étonné le
public avec une parenthèse personnelle
éloigné du pupitre la voix basse elle
est revenu sur son enfance et ses échecs
un moment d'intimité pour fendre
l'armure étoffer son capital sympathie
et peut-être se démarquer d'un rival
toujours aussi menaçants dans les
intentions de vote